que j'entends bien mais ce que je
comprends pas dans ton propos mathieu
c'est que tu nous expliques il ya deux
minutes que si tu avais pu faire autre
chose en ta vie en restant dans des
écoutes qui j'ai pu repêcher en train de
tuer en train de le dire là il a dit à
deux minutes que si c'était à refaire il
ne ferait pas ensuite il nous dit qu'il
a travaillé six ans chez nrj 12 ont
concédé avec un contrat non non non mais
pendant six ans pas à 1500 euros par
mois
non on avait l'occasion de ouvrir son
restaurant ou de changer de vie puisque
tu es tu es dedans et on a menacé en
disant si tu vois aux prud'hommes
tu feras plus jamais de télé et toi t'as
rien dit et partitas près tout mais
quand tu étais dans la rue
renate madame ça j'allais changer là-bas
d'autant le dollar est dans ton jeu de
l'allumer abc avait l'occasion prévient
il on les choisit dans les choix de
métier dur à demba sy non mais tu peut
pas décréter je vais pourquoi je vais
faire des passes que ça c'est 500 s'est
pourtant dit qu'il ya des gens de ta
famille tu chaque parfois tu as des
enfants que tincu cap ou parfois ça peut
être des parents
entretien tout d'un coup tu as vu et des
pussy libre pour donc à chaque fois
qu'un garçon a fait virer j'aurai
toujours à charge de quinquas se fait
virer de son travail il retourne à la
télévente forcément nommé dominique
quand t'auras fini de rembourser son
emprunt et je te souhaite le plus vite
on se souvient de son seul ami le poète
dans quelques zones littorales copper
encore on te proposera une émission
vedette de tamra je la prendrai pas tu
sais pas non mais c'est moi pour ce que
je fais moi je m'amuse ici je fais des
rôdeurs de remboursement anticipé gétaz
me sens je suis descendu à 1 112 année
et peut-être même qu'au mois de juin
et bien sûr vous pouvez pas dire ça
mon fils et ma vie auprès les chanter
j'ai voulu parler c'est un manque de
respect pour les trials attention
peut-être attaché à vous on ne peut pas
dire je ne sais pas c'est parce que je
ne sais pas si je me fais d'abord je
n'aurais pas autant de pognon je dis
juste que je ne suis pas fait pour la
télé je ne suis pas faire des vagues à
toi ô ô 10 dollars il est parfait pour
il dit je vais faire du pognon banon il
vient donner quelque chose comme janeiro
à la télépathe lié tout ça mais ça paye
trop tôt